ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRACIN NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM. THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. ARAMBULA
BARRICADE HAND. BENNETT'S
BERMAN. BIGELOW BLOOM.
BOERNER HORVATH BRIAN BURKE
CALDERON CARRILLO CERVANTES
CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI COOLEY
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY
DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY LACKEY LIII LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN QUINN
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS LOOSE REBAJAS
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO C. R. TO SMITH.
STONE TAMED GALLAGHER AS THE
APPROVED WALK VOEPEL WALDRON
BOARD WEBER WICKS. WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN
THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK OUR GUESTS
AND VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER. IT
IS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED BY
OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN. IMAM
YASIR KHAN IMAM YES SIR. IN THE
NAME OF GOD THE MOST GRACIOUS
THE MOST MERCIFUL. HOW MANY GOD.
BLESS THIS ASSEMBLY TODAY. FILL
ALL OF US WITH YOUR SPIRIT OF
LOVE. FORGIVENESS AND PEACE MAY
OUR PRAYERS BE BROAD AND DEEP.
MAY OUR WORDS SPRING FORTH FROM
HEARTS PURIFIED BY YOUR
GUIDANCE AND OUR ACTIONS
MANIFEST YOUR POWER TAKING ROOT
IN US. AND ALL WE SAY AND DO.
MAY WE GROW IN AWARENESS THAT
YOU ALONE SHALL RETURN TO AT
ALL TIMES I MEAN. WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
WICKS. READY BEGIN I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE. OKAY. INDIVISIBLE
YEAH. THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY GERMAN
SACRAMENTO TUESDAY JUNE FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE ASSEMBLY
READ AT ONE PM THE AUDIBLE
KEVIN MULLIN SPEAKER PRO
TEMPORE OF THE ASSEMBLY
PRESIDING CHIEF CLERK SUPPORT
OF THE DEATHS REPORTED A MOMENT
READING WILL CALL THE ROLL IS
CALLED MISTER RAMOS MOVES. AND
MISS WALDRON SECONDS THAT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH
PRESENTATIONS HAVE PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ. IT'S
DEEMED AT. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE. MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY FOR LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA FOR ILLNESS IN
THE FAMILY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES. MEMBERS JUST A QUICK
NOTE THAT YESTERDAY WAS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEAVES BIRTHDAY
HIS ACTUAL BIRTHDAY MR LEAVE.
HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO YOU SIR. AND
MAYES RACE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE ONE
EIGHT EIGHT TO ALLOW THE
SPEAKER TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR
TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE. TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
COOLEY MEDINA AND BLOWN TO
SPEAK ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER. PLEASE
REMOVE THE FOLLOWING ITEMS FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS
SIXTY ONE SB TWO NINETY TWO
WILL PROVIDE AG WE ARE CURRY
ITEM SIXTY SIX SB SEVEN SEVEN
NINE BECKER BY THE AUTHOR. I AM
SIXTY SEVEN SB SEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR GLACIER BY IT LOOSE RIVAS
AND ITEM SEVENTY FIVE SB FIFTY
TWO DODD BY AG WE ARE CURRY.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE. PURSUANT
TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE
REFER SB ONE FORTY FOUR
PORTANTINO FROM THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE TO THE REVENUE AND
TAXATION COMMITTEE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. I MOVE TO SUSPEND JOINT
RULE SIXTY TWO AA THE FINAL
NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE
REVENUE AND TAXATION COMMITTEE
HERE SB ONE FORTY FOUR
PORTANTINO AFTER HEARING ON
WEDNESDAY JULY FOURTEENTH.
THANK YOU HIS ARREST MR FLOOR
FOR PURPOSE SIR WITHHOLDING
HOUSE CONSENT AS ROLL CALL
VOTE. MISTER FLORA IS
WITHHOLDING UNANIMOUS CONSENT.
MS REYES MOVES AND MISTER CHOW
SECONDS ON THE RULES SUSPENSION
MEMBERS THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. IS RAMOS IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE MISTER FLORA IS ASKING
FOR A NO VOTE. MS RAMOS IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE AND MR
FLORA A NO VOTE ON THE RULE
SUSPENSION. CLARK WELL CLOSER
ROLE HIGHS FORTY SIX KNOWS
FOURTEEN. THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED. MISS REYES YOUR
AGAIN RECOGNIZE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO WITHDRAW
AB FOUR EIGHT TO WARD FROM
ENROLLMENT AND ORDER THE BILL
HELD AT THE DESK. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING COOKERY SENATE
BILL SEVEN FIFTY SIX OF THE
MEMBERS SEVEN TWENTY FIVE OF
THE MEMBERS FOR FIFTY SIX WITH
A MINISTRY NINETY SIX FOR THE
MEMBERS AND SENATE BILL THREE
SEVENTY TWO WITH A MENACE. ALL
BILLS WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
CONCURRENCE. WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF CONCURRENCE ITEMS. THIS IS
CONCURRENCE IN THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS. FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SIX A. B. SIX THIRTY THREE. THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
SIX THIRTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CALDERON AND
ACCORDING TO CIVIL ACTIONS.
MEMBERS. YOUR ATTENTION IS
CALDERON IS CALDERON YOU MAY
OPEN AT THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS AB SIX THIRTY THREE
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE MINOR AND
TECHNICAL IN NATURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. TAKING HIS CALDERON SEE
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CLICK LOCAL THE ROLE ALL
MEMBERS OF. IT IS AT ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRABLE.
CLARK WELL.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE A
ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY FIVE
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS THIS IS
FILE ITEM. SEVEN FILE ITEM
SEVEN A. B. SEVEN TWENTY SIX.
BY MISTER EDUARDO GARCIA THE
CLERK WILL READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN TWENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
AN ACT RELATING TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT MR GARCIA YOU MAY
OPEN MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES IS BILLS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED NO. ZERO NO VOTES
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MISTER CSE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS OF.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF THE PRESIDING VOTE. CLICK
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I.
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO SEVEN
AMENDMENTS. PARKING CURTIN PASS
RETAIN A FILE ITEMS EIGHT AND
NINE. THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
TEN AB FIFTEEN NINETY THREE.
CORRECT ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
NINETY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LORENA GONZALEZ AN ACCOLADE TO
SAY CLAIMS A MAKING A
PROBATIONER FOR DECLARING YOUR
SIERRA PACIFIC MEDIALLY. THIS
GONZALEZ YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU. MISTER SPEAKER AB FIFTEEN
NINETY THREE THE
CONSTITUTIONALLY REQUIRED BUILT
APPROPRIATE FUNDS FOR PROOF
CLAIMS AGAINST THE STATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT.
THANK YOU BUSINESS HOURS SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
LOCAL OF NARAL. ALL MEMBERS OF.
YOU DESERVE IT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS AT ABOUT CLERK WELL.
CLOSE A ROLL TIDE ABOUT I.
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS. MARK INTERRED IN.
THIS IS. FILE ITEM ELEVEN ACR
NINETY. THE CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY CURRENT RESOLUTION
NINETY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS AND OTHER SORTS OF THE
USS LIBERTY REMEMBRANCE DAY.
MISTER MATHIS. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS BILL IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE WE SIMPLY
ADDED THE WORD REMEMBRANCE TO
THE USS LIBERTY REMEMBRANCE DAY
ASK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE. ON
THE ADAM CORPORAL OF THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRABLE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF- I TO
VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO. SENATE AMENDMENTS WORKING
CURTAIN. FILE I'M TWELVE IS.
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY EIGHT. PARK
RIDGE ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
SEVENTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK SILVA AND OTHERS AN ACT
RELATING TO MOBILE HOMES MS
CLARK SILVA YOU MAY OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER SPEAKER AB
NINE SEVENTY EIGHT IS BACK FOR.
CONCURRENCE AND MEMONS TAKEN IN
THE SENATE WHERE DAD FINDINGS
AND DECLARATIONS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS CLARK
SILVA SEEN NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. CARPOOL OF NARAL.
MEMBERS THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLARK WELL. CLOSE A ROLL
TIDE THAT ICE SEVEN NO SIX
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTEEN.
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE MR LOW
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOGAN ACT
RELATING TO LAW ENFORCEMENT MR
LOW YOUR MAIL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISS SPEAKER RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. C. NOTIFICATION OR
DEBATE. MICHAEL THE ROLE.
RESERVE A ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRABLE. WELL AND THOSE ARE
ALL TIED UP I SIXTY SEVEN. NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS WORKING
KERN.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
THE ASSEMBLY THIRD READING FILE.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS AND RETAIN.
ON FILE ITEMS FIFTEEN. AND.
SIXTEEN MEMBERS WE ARE AT FILE
ITEM. SEVENTEEN ACR. NINETY
FOUR. BY MS VALLADARES. COOKERY
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
NINETY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
VALLADARES RELATIVE TO FIRST
LADY NANCY DAVIS REAGAN IS
VALID THERE SHE MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO PROBABLY PRESENT
ACR NINETY FOUR SO THE
LEGISLATURE MAY HONOR THE LIFE
AND LEGACY OF FORMER FIRST LADY
NANCY REAGAN ON THE CENTENNIAL
OF HER BIRTH JULY SIXTH NANCY
REAGAN WAS A REMARKABLE
INDIVIDUAL WHO SHATTERED GLASS
CEILINGS HELP ADDRESS SOME OF
AMERICA'S MOST CHALLENGING
PROBLEMS AND FOREVER REDEFINED
THE ROLE. OF FIRST LADY. IN HER
LONG LIFE NANCY REAGAN WORE
MANY HATS SHE WAS AN ACTRESS A
LOVING MOTHER. A LOVING WIFE A
TIRELESS ADVOCATE FOR SEVERAL
IMPORTANT CAUSES AND OF COURSE
FIRST LADY OF BOTH CALIFORNIA
AND THE UNITED STATES. AND
THROUGHOUT HER LIFE SHE
ACCOMPLISHED SO MUCH SHE RAISE
AWARENESS ABOUT THE DANGERS OF
DRUG AND ALCOHOL ABUSE SHE
PASSIONATELY ADVOCATED FOR
WOMEN'S HEALTH. SHE SUPPORTED
AMERICA'S VETERANS AND SHE
CHAMPIONED THE NEED FOR
RESEARCH INTO THE PREVENTION
TREATMENT AND CURE FOR
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE. SHE NEVER
GAVE UP ON THE CAUSES AND
ISSUES THAT MATTERED. I BELIEVE
IT IS LONG OVERDUE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
RECOGNIZE THE LIFE AND LEGACY
OF NANCY REAGAN AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE. THANK
YOU MISS OUT THERE'S- MR LEE
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER WELL THANK YOU TO
SPEAKER MEMBERS I JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT IT IS COMPLETELY
INAPPROPRIATE FOR US TO BE
HONORING ENTIRE YEAR FOR THE
FORMER LADY NANCY REAGAN THIS
HOUSE PRIDES ISELF IN PROGRESS
IN UNDOING THE HARM OF MASS
INCARCERATION AND THE WAR ON
DRUGS FINANCI REAGAN. OF THE
GREAT MANY THINGS HE DID IN OUR
LIFE WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE ALSO
THE ON AND WELL THE
CONSEQUENCES OF HER ACTIONS ARE
LEGACY SOME OF THESE CONSERVE
SOME OF THESE ACTIONS YOU HAVE
TO REMEMBER IS THINGS LIKE
ADVOCATING AGAINST THE EQUAL
RIGHTS AMENDMENT IN ORDER RENT
ALL GENDERS ARE HAVING EQUAL
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS AND THE
DETRIMENTAL ROLE HER AND
PRESIDENT REAGAN PLAYED IN THE
AIDS CRISIS THAT RAVAGED OUR
LGBTQ PLUS COMMUNITY IN THE
EIGHTIES THIS LED TO TENS OF
DYING
FINALLY HER DISASTROUS THREE
WORD SLOGAN JUST SAY NO WAS THE
NEXT EVOLUTION OF THE WAR ON
DRUGS MAKING DRUG USE A MORAL
FAILING AND FOR ANYONE THAT HAS
GROWN UP IN THE PAST SEVERAL
DECADES YOU ALSO WENT THROUGH A
PROGRAM PROBABLY CALIFORNIA
CALLED THERE WHICH I WENT
THROUGH THAT IS PROVEN NOT TO
BE EFFECTIVE IN FACT IT FAILED
TO REDUCE DRUG USE AMONG YOUTH
WHILE COSTING TAXPAYERS SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
WHEN IT WAS. WHEN IT WAS ACTIVE
pFAILED WAR ON DRUGS HAVE GIVEN
RISE TO HARMFUL IDEAS THAT LED
TO EXTREME SENTENCING FOR
NONVIOLENT CRIMES AND MASS
INCARCERATION SO MEMBERS I ASK
YOU DAN THE WORDS NANCY REAGAN
JUST SAY NO. THIS RESOLUTION
THANK YOU. MS WALDRON. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY IN TRIBUTE
TO NANCY REAGAN FIRMER FORMER
FIRST LADY NANCY REAGAN WAS AN
INCREDIBLE CREDIBLY DISTINGUISH
FIRST LADY AND A GREAT WOMAN IN
AMERICAN HISTORY UPON HER
PASSING A PROMINENT POLITICAL
FIGURE SAID. SHE UNDERSTOOD
PUBLIC SERVICE AS A NOBLE
ENDEAVOR SHE WAS A STRONG VOICE
TO KEEP CHILDREN SAFE FROM
DRUGS AND SHE REACHED OUT TO
GIVE COMFORT TO FELLOW CANCER
SURVIVORS. IMMUNITIES TOUCHED
BY GUN VIOLENCE AND FAMILIES AS
THEY CARED FOR A LOVED ONE ON
THE LONELY WALK OF ALZHEIMER'S.
THAT QUOTE WAS BY PRESIDENT JOE
BIDEN I URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK
WHICH WATER MISTER FLORA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ACR NINETY FOUR
NANCY REAGAN WAS ACCREDITED AS
A PROGRESSIVE FORCE THAT
FINALLY. PUSH THE REAGAN
ADMINISTRATION INTO TAKING
DECISIVE ACTION TO GROWING AIDS
CRISIS INCLUDING FUNDING. AND
WE'RE GOING TO GO ON THIS FLOOR
AN HONOR THE MEN AND WOMEN LIKE
WE ALWAYS DO. NONE OF US. ON
THIS FOR A PERFECT. SO THOSE
AMONG US AT A PERFECT CAST THE
FIRST STONE AND I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ACR NINETY
FOUR. MISTER BIGELOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. MEMBERS I RISE AND
REYES MY MICROPHONE IN TRIBUTE
TO NANCY REAGAN I ALSO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF ACR NINETY FOUR. I'M
MARCH SIXTH. TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN. THEN GOVERNOR JERRY
BROWN HONORED NANCY REAGAN
ORDERING THE CAPITALS FLAGS TO
BE FLOWN AT HALF STAFF IN
STATING AND I QUOTE SHE LIVED A
REMARKABLE LIFE AND WILL BE
REMEMBERED FOR HER STRENGTH AND
GRACE FOREVER. MEMBERS LET US
RESPECT THIS LADY WHO GAVE SO
MUCH OF HER LIFE AND TIME TO
THE PEOPLE OF NOT ONLY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT THIS
GREAT NATION SHE SERVED HER
HUSBAND WHILE SHE SERVED THE
MEN AND WOMEN AND THE CHILDREN
OF THIS GREAT STATE. AND NATION.
LET'S DO THIS PROPER HONOR
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. I WAS
BIGELOW MS DALLY YOUR RECOGNIZE.
I RAISE MY MIKE TODAY IN
TRIBUTE OF NANCY REAGAN SHE WAS
A STRONG ADVOCATE FOR ARTS BOTH
AS AN ACTRESS AND AS FOR THE
FIRST LADY SHE GAVE YOUNG
ARTISTS A FORUM ON MULTIPLE
OCCASIONS THROUGHOUT HER LIFE
MOST NOTABLY BY USING THE
EXECUTIVE MANSION AS A SHOWCASE
FOR TALENTED YOUNG PERFORMERS
IN THE PBS TELEVISION SERIES IN
PERFORMANCE AT THE WHITE HOUSE
I URGE WE SUPPORT. ACR NINETY
FOUR. MR LACKEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. YES OVER SPEAKER
MEMBERS- PERMISSION ARRANGEMENT
MISTER SPEAKER. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. NANCY REAGAN
REDEFINED THE ROLE OF THE FIRST
LADY OF THE UNITED STATES. IN
ADDITION TO SERVING AS A
TRUSTED ADVISER TO HER HUSBAND
AND ELEGANT HOSTESS FOR OUR
NATION. SHE WAS A PASSIONATE
ADVOCATE FOR ISSUES THAT TOUCH
THE LIVES OF SO MANY. SHE
RAISED AWARENESS ABOUT DRUG AND
ALCOHOL ABUSE. SHE WAS A
STAUNCH SUPPORTER OF AMERICA'S
VETERANS. AND AFTER HER OWN
BATTLE WITH BREAST CANCER AND A
MASTECTOMY SHE SPOKE IN
PERSONAL TERMS ABOUT THE NEED
FOR WOMEN TO GET MAMMOGRAMS.
MEMBERS THAT IS FORMER
PRESIDENT OBAMA WHEN HE THOUGHT
OF NANCY REAGAN. I WOULD
CERTAINLY HOPE THE DEBUT WOULD
DO HER THE TRIBUTE AND SUPPORT
OF THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE.
THANK MISS LACKEY MR FONG YOUR
RECOGNIZE. I THANK YOU AS A
SPEAKER. A HIGH TO RISE IN
TRIBUTE TO NANCY REAGAN. AFTER
A HUSBAND DIAGNOSED WITH
DIAGNOSIS WITH ALZHEIMER'S
DISEASE FIRST LADY NANCY REAGAN
BECAME A TIRELESS ADVOCATE FOR
A CURE FOR THE DISEASE AND FOR
THOSE AFFECTED BY. THE A RP
DEEMED HER QUOTE THE NATION'S
HIGHEST PROFILE ALZHEIMER'S
CAREGIVER AYE URGENT AYE VOTE
ON ACR NINETY FOUR. MISTER
PATTERSON YOUR RECOGNIZE. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I TO RAISE
MY MIKE IN TRIBUTE TO NANCY
REAGAN. AND I DO SO WITH A
QUOTE FROM A PROMINENT
INDIVIDUAL. NANCY REAGAN WAS AN
EXTRAORDINARY WOMAN THAT
REDEFINED THE ROLE OF THE FIRST
LADY. AND LEFT A LASTING MARK
IN THE FIGHT TO TREAT THOSE
SUFFERING FROM ALZHEIMER'S AND
QUOTE. THE AUTHOR OF THAT
TRIBUTE WAS. KAMALA HARRIS VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
MR VOEPEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RAISE
MY MARK CONTRIBUTE TO NANCY
REAGAN NANCY REAGAN IS WELL
KNOWN FOR SPEAKING OUT AGAINST
DRUG AND ALCOHOL ABUSE BY YOUNG
PEOPLE SHE DEVELOPED THE JUST
SAY NO CAMPAIGN WHICH SURE
BEATS GO SEE YOUR LOCAL DOPE
DEALER. SOON POWER YOUNG PEOPLE
TO RESIST THE INFLUENCE OF
ILLEGAL SUBSTANCES THANK YOU.
MISTER SMITH YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MISTER SPEAKER DIP MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I RIDE MY BIKE IN
TRIBUTE OF NANCY REAGAN. DURING
REGULAR VISITS TO THE ELDERLY
NANCY WITH THE REAGAN BECAME A
PROPONENT FOR THE FOSTER
GRANDPARENT PROGRAM. A PROGRAM
THAT BRINGS TOGETHER SENIOR
CITIZENS AS MENTORS TUTORS AND
COMPANION TO CHILDREN'S WITH
EXCEPTIONAL NEEDS. SHE SOON
BECAME ITS CHAMPION HELPING TO
EXPAND THE PROGRAM ON A
NATIONAL LEVEL IMPROVE AND
PROMOTE INCREASE FUNDING FOR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. NANCY REAGAN
WAS AN EXCEPTIONAL WOMAN AND AN
ADVOCATE FOR THOSE THAT ARE ALL
TOO OFTEN FORGOTTEN. SHE IS
WORTHY OF A RECOGNITION TODAY.
AND I URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR ACR.
NINETY FOUR. I MISS DAVIS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RAISE MY CONTRIBUTED
NANCY REAGAN AS FIRST LADY
NANCY REAGAN PUBLICLY REVEALED
HER BREAST CANCER DIAGNOSIS AND
DECISION TO UNDERGO A
MASTECTOMY HER WILLINGNESS TO
SHARE A CONDITION ENCOURAGED
MANY WOMEN TO SEEK MEDICAL
ADVICE AND HAVE MAMMOGRAMS. THE
NANCY REAGAN BREAST CENTER AT
ADVOCATE IS HEALTHY ME VALLEY
IN VENTURA COUNTY UNDER THE
PRIMER FIRST LADIES
CONTRIBUTION FOR FIGHTING
BREAST CANCER I ASKED FOR AN I.
ACR NINETY FOUR. THANK YOU MISS
DAVIS AND DR QUIRK. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. YES BOB I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF ACR NINETY FOUR WE
ALL HAVE. WELL MOST OF US HAVE.
SPOUSES PARTNERS AND WE KNOW
THIS SICK THE SACRIFICES THEY
MAKE SO WE CAN DO WHAT WE THINK
IS RIGHT. AND I MAY NOT AGREE
WITH EVERYTHING THAT THE
REAGANS DID. BUT I DO AGREE
THAT- SHE- LIKE MANY OTHERS
LIKE OUR SPOUSES AND PARTNERS
ARE DEDICATED HER LIFE. TO
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE LIKE US
COULD IN FACT. PURSUER ARE
POLITICAL CAREER AND BELIEVE ME
YOU CAN'T DO IT WITHOUT SUPPORT
FROM A SPOUSE MANY OF US KNOW
THIS. NOT ALL MARRIAGES SURVIVE
IT AND FOR THAT REASON I
SUPPORT A SHE NOT ARE NINETY
FOUR. THANK YOU THAT CORRECT MR
SAY ARE TELL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY I RAISE
MY MIGHT IN TRIBUTE TO NANCY
REAGAN. I WOULD LIKE TO START
BY READING A QUOTE. AS PER
SECTION THANK YOU AS FIRST LADY
NANCY REAGAN DEVOTED HER TIME
AND ENERGY DEFINING DRUG USE
AMONG CHILDREN AND YOUNG ADULTS
BRINGING NATIONAL ATTENTION TO
THE ISSUE WITH HER JUST SAY NO
CAMPAIGN. A LOVING AND
NURTURING WIFE MOTHER NANCY
REAGAN DEVOTED HERSELF TO
CARING FOR PRESIDENT REAGAN
DURING HIS BOT BATTLE WITH
ALZHEIMER'S. I READ THIS QUOTE
BY THE HONORABLE SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE NANCY PELOSI BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT MANY CHILDREN.
POSSIBLY EVEN MY OWN WERE
INSPIRED BY THE JUST SAY NO
CAMPAIGN. WHILE THE WAR ON
DRUGS HAD MANY OUTCOMES NANCY
REAGAN'S CAMPAIGN TO JUST SAY
NO. CAPTURED THE HEARTS AND
COUNTLESS YOUNG MINDS YOUNG
MINDS THAT SAID NO TO DRUGS AND
WOUND UP LIVING FRUITFUL AND
PRODUCTIVE LIVES DUE TO THAT
CHOICE. WE MAY BE ABLE TO
MEASURE THE IMPACT OF THOSE
IMPACTED BY DRUGS WE MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO MEASURE THE IMPACT OF
THOSE IMPACTED BY DRUGS BUT WE
CANNOT MEASURE THE INFINITE
IMPACTS BY THOSE WHO JUST SAY
NO. IT IS FOR THOSE REASONS
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON ACR NINETY
FOUR THANK YOU. HEY DOCTOR CHOI
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
SPEAKER AND A MEMBERS SO I
RELEASED MY MARCH IN TRIBUTE TO
THE NANCY REAGAN NANCY DAVIS
REAGAN FIRST LADY OF THE UNITED
STATES FROM. NINETEEN EIGHTY
ONE TO NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE WAS
SO AWARDED GO WITH THE
CONGRESSIONAL GOLD MEDAL. THE
CONGRESSIONAL GOLD MEDAL IS ON
OVER THE BEST THE BY THE UNITED
STATES CONGRESS. IT IS SO
CONGRESO HIGHEST EXPRESSION ABA
NATIONAL APPRECIATION FOR
DISTINGUISHED DOT US OR TWO
MONTHS AND THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
BY INDIVIDUALS OR INSTITUTIONS.
THIS AUTHORED HONORING NANCY
REAGAN WAS APPROVED IN
LEGISLATION AND ASSIGNED A BY
DEMOCRATS THE PRESS AND BILL
CLINTON. RECOGNIZING HER
SERVICE TO THE NATION. NANCY
REAGAN WAS ALSO AWARDED THE
PRESIDENTIAL MEDAL OF FREEDOM
IN TWO THOUSAND TWO. I ASK FOR
YOUR ARRIVAL. ON A C. R. MY
FOUR ON THOSE AND THE LEGO OF
ONE MAN'S DAY ARRAY. THANK YOU.
HEY DOUG CHOI MISTER MATHIS
YOUR RECORD. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. I TO RAISE MY
CONTRIBUTE TO NANCY REAGAN.
UPON BECOMING THE FIRST LADY OF
CALIFORNIA IN NINETEEN SIXTY
SEVEN A CORNERSTONE OF NANCY
REAGAN'S TENURE WAS THE SISTIN
OUR VIETNAM VETERANS. HER
TIRELESS WORK AND DEDICATION
WAS CLEAR AS SHE PUBLICLY
SUPPORTED IN CHAMPION. FOR THE
RIGHTS IN CARE OVER VIETNAM
VETERANS PRISONERS OF WAR AND
THOSE MISSING IN ACTION. NANCY
REGULARLY. REGULARLY THEN
PROBABLY VISITED. VIETNAM WAR
VETERANS IN HOSPITALS SHE ALSO
DONATED HER OWN SALARY FROM A
NEWSPAPER COLUMN TO THE
NATIONAL LEAGUE OF FAMILIES OF
AMERICAN P. O. W. IN MY EIGHT.
NANCY REAGAN WAS TRULY
INSPIRING FIGURE AND HER LEGACY
AND WORK WITHIN THE VETERAN
COMMUNITY CONTINUES TO THIS DAY
MEMBERS I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
ON ACR NINETY FOUR THANK YOU.
MISSION WHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF ACR NINETY FOUR
AS WE HONOR THE LIFE AND LEGACY
OF NANCY DAVIS REAGAN I COMMEND
HER FOR LIFE DEDICATE TO THE
SERVICE OF OUR GREAT NATION AND
OUR STATE. THE REAGANS WERE
AVID SUPPORTERS OF THE
VIETNAMESE REFUGEES MIGRATION.
HI MY FAMILY THE FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND VIETNAMESE AMERICANS
AND MILLIONS OF VIETNAMESE
REFUGEES ALL ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY WOULD NOT BE HERE. I
WOULD NOT BE STANDING HERE IN
FRONT OF YOU. IF IT WERE NOT
FOR THE SUPPORT FROM NANCY
REAGAN AND HER HUSBAND. I WILL
ALWAYS CELEBRATE THIS
ADMINISTRATION WHO SUPPORTED MY
FAMILY. THE VENOMOUS REFUGEE AS
WE CAME TO AMERICA ON A BOAT IN
SEARCH OF FREEDOM AND
DEMOCRACY. CELEBRATING OUR
FIRST LADIES LADY NANCY
REAGAN'S BIRTHDAY SHOULD NOT BE
A PARTISAN ISSUE AT ALL. NO
MATTER YOUR PARTY OR POLITICAL
IDEOLOGY THIS IS A SAD DAY FOR
AMERICA NANCY REAGAN WAS AN
EXEMPLARY FIRST LADY. SENATOR
BERNIE SANDERS I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND ACR. NINETY FOUR.
THANK YOU MR WHEN MR COOLEY
YOUR REFERENCE. COLLEAGUES I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION I THINK. IN OUR
PUBLIC LIFE I SHARE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM FREMONT. THIS
THOUGHT THIS IS A COUPLE.
WHATEVER THE POLICIES OF THE
HUSBAND. THEY WERE WED FOR
FIFTY TWO YEARS. YOU KNOW WHEN
THEY GOT MARRIED IN NINETEEN
FIFTY TWO THE LIFE TO UNFOLD
FOR HER HUSBAND WAS NOT IN
PROSPECT. SHE WAS A BRIGHT ABLE
LADY ACCOMPLISH OUR OWN RIGHT.
AND FOR FIVE DECADES.
SUBORDINATED HERSELF FOR
OUTLOOK FOR INTEREST TO THE
CAREER OF HER HUSBAND THAT'S
NOT ANY MAN CAN DO THAT WE NOW
SEE THAT IN THE VICE
PRESIDENT'S OFFICE A MAN WHO IS
SO BORED AND SELF TO THE WHITE
TO HIS WIFE'S CAREER. BUT THIS
IS COMMENDABLE BY ANY MEASURE
THE- DEVOTION AND THEN OF
COURSE OTHERS ALWAYS HAVE
PROSPECT WILL IT'S NOT FUN NOW
BUT IT WILL LAND AND I'LL HAVE
MY SPOUSE BACK AND OF COURSE
ALZHEIMER'S INTERVENED TO SET
THAT OFF THE RAILS FOR A
DECADE. AND THEIR LIFE TOGETHER.
SO ACROSS FIFTY YEARS ALL THE
WAS INVOLVED BEING THE SPOUSE
OF A PUBLIC FIGURE IN DURING
ALZHEIMER'S WHICH IS OF COURSE
HOW I LOST MY MOM. ANA THESE
ARE TALES. OF EXHIBITING GREAT
ENDURANCE AND CHARACTER. I
THINK IT IS RIGHT IN FIT IN IN
PUBLIC LIFE WE ARE PEOPLE IN
THIS WAY IN THE HOUSE NEXT DOOR
OF COURSE THE DEMOCRATS MEET IN
THE MATTER LOUNGE. HONORING A
PROMINENT- REPUBLICAN WITH WHOM
THEY BATTLED REGULARLY- SO I
THINK IT IS FITTING TO.
IDENTIFY OUTSTANDING QUALITIES
IN AN INDIVIDUAL THE DEBATE A
DIFFERENCE IN POLITICAL LIFE
AND WE ALL NEED THOSE IN OUR
LIFE- GINGIVAL. THANK YOU MISS
COOLEY THANK YOU MEMBERS THIS
VALLADARES. MEMBERS I'M A BIT
DISAPPOINTED I'M DISAPPOINTED
THAT THE BASELESS FALSEHOODS
WERE THAT WERE MENTIONED ON
THIS FLOOR TODAY AND WHAT I CAN
ONLY ASSUME WAS AN ATTEMPT TO
GAIN SOME. CHEAP POLITICAL
POINTS. YOU KNOW IT'S OFTEN
SAID THAT THOSE WHO DO NOT
STUDY HISTORY ARE CONDEMNED TO
REPEAT IT. TODAY I THINK IT'S
MORE ACCURATE TO SAY THAT THOSE
WHO CONDEMN HISTORY. LIKELY
HAVEN'T STUDIED IT. NANCY
REAGAN'S TRACK RATHER RECORD
SPEAKS FOR ITSELF SHE WAS A
DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANT WHO
SPENT HER TIME HELPING THOSE IN
NEED AND MADE SIGNIFICANT
POSITIVE IMPACTS ON THEIR
LIVES. THAT IS EXACTLY WHY SHE
GARNERED SO MUCH SUPPORT. FROM
INDIVIDUALS ACROSS THE
POLITICAL SPECTRUM. FORMER
FIRST LADY MICHELLE OBAMA AND
OBAMA ONCE REMARKED THAT NANCY
REAGAN WAS A PASSIONATE
ADVOCATE FOR SO MANY ISSUES WHO
REMINDED US OF THE IMPORTANCE
OF WOMEN'S LEADERSHIP. AT EVERY
LEVEL. AS A YOUNG GIRL WHO GREW
UP WHEN THE NANCY WHEN NANCY
REAGAN WAS OUR FIRST LADY I WAS
INSPIRED BY HOW SHE GOT
INVOLVED. IF YOU ARE ABLE TO
GROW UP. IN A NEIGHBORHOOD.
LIKE MINE YOU CAN'T UNDERSTAND
HOW DRUGS PLAGUED OUR COMMUNITY.
I WASN'T THERE PART OF THE DARE
PROGRAM. AND WHILE THAT JUST
SAY NO CAMPAIGN MAY NOT HAVE
SAVED EVERYONE. I SAID NOW.
SOME OF MY FRIENDS SAID NOW.
SOME OF THEM DIDN'T. SO SHE
SAID ABOUT ONE LIFE WITH THAT
CAMPAIGN. IS NOT WORTHY. OF
THIS RECOGNITION. AND WHEN AIDS
HIT MY FAMILY. SHE WAS THERE TO
PROVIDE RESOURCES. AND
AWARENESS. I DON'T KNOW WHETHER
I'D BE IN THIS POSITION TODAY
IF NOT FOR THE EXAMPLE. THAT
SHE HELPS THAT. I THINK NANCY
REAGAN IS MORE THAN DESERVING
OF THIS RECOGNITION AND I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE IN HONOR OF HER
LIFE. AND LEGACY. THANK YOU
INSTRUCTORS WE WILL TAKE A ROLL
CALL VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF L.
CLARK
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE I FORTY
NINE KNOWS FIVE. THAT
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED YEAH.
THIS IS FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN A.
C. R. TWELVE. THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION TWELVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SAY ARTS- AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO PURPLE HEART DAY MR
SAY ARE TELL YOU MAIL. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I AM
PROUD TO BRING THIS RESOLUTION
BEFORE YOU TODAY TO DECLARE
THAT THIS COMING AUGUST
SEVENTH. IS RECOGNIZED AS
PURPLE HEART DAY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. THE PURPLE HEART IS
A METAL GIVEN NOT AN
ACHIEVEMENT. BUT TO HONOR
SACRIFICE. WHILE THE PURPLE
HEART MEDAL ORIGINALLY CREATED
BY OUR FIRST PRESIDENT GEORGE
WASHINGTON WAS TO RECOGNIZE
BRAVERY IN COMBAT TODAY IT IS
USED TO RECOGNIZE THOSE WHO
WERE INJURED IN SERVICE TO OUR
COUNTRY BY THE ACTIONS OF OUR
ENEMY. THIS SIMPLE PURPLE
RIBBON TRIMMED WITH WHITE
HOLDING A BRONZE HEART WITH THE
PORTRAIT OF PRESIDENT
WASHINGTON. DENOTES THE HIGHEST
RESPECT AND HONOR WE CAN WHAT
ARE WE AS A COUNTRY CAN BESTOW.
IT IS ESTIMATED THAT OVER ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION SERVICE
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN AWARDED THIS
MEDAL. MANY POST HUMOROUSLY. I
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
REMEMBER OUR SERVICE MEMBERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES FOR THEIR
SACRIFICES FOR WITHOUT THEIR
SACRIFICES WE COULD NOT ENJOY
THE VESTIGES OF FREEDOM WE HAVE
TODAY. IT IS WITH THOSE
THOUGHTS THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND
RECOGNIZE AUGUST SEVENTH AS
PURPLE HEART DAY. IN HONOR OF
ITS CREATION AND. SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU MISTER
SERTA MISTER MATHIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS IS ONE OF THE
FEW OF THIS BODY THAT. HOLDS
WHAT- ME AND MY. THE FELLOW
VETERANS TEND TO CALL THE ENEMY
MARKSMANSHIP BADGE- MANY OF US
NEVER ONE OF THESE THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE- LIVE THROUGH-
IN SOMETHING THAT WE CARRY WITH
US. EVERY SINGLE DAY OF OUR
LIVES. I JUST ASK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. ON PURPLE HEART DAY
AND ON THIS RESOLUTION THANK
YOU. MISSION WHEN YOU'RE
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
ACR TWELVE. IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN. I WAS ABLE TO GET THE
COUNTY OF ORANGE TO DEDICATE
OUR COUNTY AS PURPLE HEART
COUNTY. FEW YEARS LATER I WAS
ABLE TO GET. ALL THIRTY FOUR
CITIES IN ORANGE COUNTY ALSO
DEDICATE THEMSELF AS PURPLE
HEART CITY. WE OWED IT TO THESE
MEN AND WOMEN WHO SACRIFICED
EVERYTHING TO CONTINUE TO ALLOW
US TO HAVE THE FREEDOM AND
DEMOCRACY WE DESERVE AND GET
AND HAVE IN THIS GREAT COUNTRY.
SO HONORING THEM IS THE LEAST
WE COULD DO. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION.
THEY MISSED WHEN MR COOLEY
CORRECTNESS. I WANT TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS IS DAY IN A FEW
MINUTES I'LL HAVE THE HONOR OF
RETURN IN MEMORY OF A
CONSTITUENT OF MINE. BUT OF.
YOU KNOW WE HEAR THE PURPLE
HEART YOU SORT OF FORGET WHAT'S
INVOLVED. I WILL SPEAK TODAY IN
HONOR OF A GENTLEMAN WHO. WAS A
RADIO OPERATOR ON A B.
SEVENTEEN. THAT MEANS HE HAD
THE ROLE OF GUIDING HIS SHIP IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE NAVIGATOR
WATCHING FOR IF AIRCRAFT FELL
OUT OF THE SKY THAT HE MIGHT.
MAINTAIN A RECORD OF THAT.
AFTER A BOMBING HE LOOKED TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL THE BOMBS
HAD FALLEN OUT OF. AIRCRAFT AND
NONE WERE HUNG UP PUT EVERYBODY
IN JEOPARDY. AN EXISTING YOU
NOTE THAT THE PURPLE HEART
DATES TO AUGUST SEVENTH. THIS
GENTLEMAN WILL. RECEIVE HIS
PURPLE HEART FOR INJURIES AROSE
ON AUGUST NINTH. NINETEEN FORTY
FOUR IN A B. SEVENTEEN SO THAT
MEANS HE WAS. THAT AIRCRAFT WAS
BUILT FOR DAYTIME FLYING INTO
THE WAR ZONE. AND IF YOU KNOW
YOUR HISTORY THAT MEANS IN
AUGUST OF NINETEEN FORTY FOUR
ON THE NINE. THE NORMANDY
INVASION HAD SUCCEEDED IN
BREAKING OUT JUST ABOUT A WEEK
BEFORE. THE FRENCH INVASION WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN IN A WEEK. SO
HE WAS IN CRITICAL AIRBORNE
MISSIONS AND DAYTIME INTO
EUROPEAN THEATER WHEN THE
BALANCE OF WORLD WAR TWO WAS IN
THE PROCESS OF CHANGING. SO ON
A VERY IMPORTANT ROLE IN A VERY
IMPORTANT AIRCRAFT IN A VERY
IMPORTANT TIME HE WAS INJURED
AND THAT'S KIND OF THE STORY OF
EVERYBODY. WHO EARNS A PURPLE
HEART. SO I JUST WANT TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS IT IS A- OUR
NATION'S OLDEST RECOGNITION. OF
SERVICE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS COOLEY. SEE NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION MR
SIERRA YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU
WISH THANK YOU COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND THAT THE
FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR
COOPER'S. MISTER SERRA IS
ASKING FOR CO AUTHORS CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. NEVER
CEASES FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. ON THE RESOLUTION FOR
CO AUTHORS. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSER ROLE THERE SEVENTY FIVE
CO AUTHORS ADDED IN WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE. ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE EYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM
NINETEEN SENATE THIRD READING
PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEMS TWENTY
THROUGH. TWENTY TWO. THIS IS
FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE SB FOUR
TWENTY SEVEN. THE CLERK WILL
READ. SENATE BILL FOR TWENTY
SEVEN BY CENTER EGGMAN
ACCORDING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
MISTER COOPER. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS SB FOUR TWENTY
SEVEN SIX TO PROTECT THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF OUR LOCAL WATER
SUPPLIES BY HEFTY PENALTIES FOR
WATER THEFT THE BILL AUTHORIZES
LOCAL WATER AGENCIES TO
INCREASE WATER FAT POLICE BY
DROPPING AN ORDNANCE. WHAT IF
THEY'RE PRESENT A SERIOUS
PUBLIC HEALTH THREAT FROM CROSS
CONTAMINATION THAT CAN OCCUR
WHEN NOT POSSIBLE SOURCES ARE
CONNECTED TO A WATER SYSTEM
THREE FIRE HYDRANTS AND OTHER
NOT POSSIBLE CONNECTIONS WHAT
PROVIDERS HAVE PROCESSES IN
PLACE TO PERMIT THE PURCHASES
OF WATER BUT FARE FROM HYDRANTS
POSIBLE SERIOUS HEALTH RISKS.
WHEN ANTI BACKFLOW DEVICES ARE
NOT USE SB FOUR TWENTY SEVEN
WILL HELP DETER WATER THEFT
INITIALLY THE HEALTH AN SAFETY
OF WATER SUPPLIES FOR MILLIONS
OF USERS ACROSS THE STATE.
THERE'S ARTICLES WE CAN THE L.
A. TIMES TO TALK ABOUT AMONGST
OTHER THINGS HYPERVALENT WATER
THEFT IS IN OUR STATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. FAMOUS COOPER. SEE NO
OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. CLICK LIBERAL
MEMBERS. HE DESIRED ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. TO DECIDE ABOUT.
THE CLERK WILL. THE CLOSER ROLE.
CALVET AYE SEVENTY TWO KNOWS
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A SPECIAL
PRESENTATION. MISTER SPEAKER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FROM YOUR
DESK IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS MEMBERS HI I HOPE YOU
ALL HAVE COME TO REALIZE THAT
ONE OF THE REALLY COOL THINGS
ABOUT OUR JOBS AS WE GET TO
WORK WITH SOME PRETTY AMAZING
STAFF. DURING MY FIVE YEARS AS
SPEAKER OF THIS HOUSE I'VE BEEN
LUCKY ENOUGH TO INCLUDE LISA IT
NEARLY AS ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE
IT'S BEEN MY DUTY TO APPOINT
MANY PEOPLE TO BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS THAT HELP AND SERVE
OUR STATE IT'S BEEN MY HONOR TO
HAVE WE SEE EASILY HANDLING
MUCH OF THE BEHIND THE SCENES
WORK FOR THESE APPOINTMENTS I
AM TO SIX SPEAKER SHE HAS
SERVED WITHIN THAT CAPACITY
THOUGH I'M SURE I'M A FAVORITE-
ABSOLUTELY- BEFORE THAT CHAVEZ
SR SEVERAL INDIVIDUAL MEMBERS
OF THE ASSEMBLY IN THE SENATE.
WITH NEARLY THIRTY YEARS OF
SERVICE THE LEGISLATURE LISA
HAS DEFINITELY SEEN MUCH MORE
OF WHAT GOES ON IN THIS
BUILDING THAT I HAVE SHE'S USE
THAT EXPERIENCE TO OFFER
INVALUABLE SERVICE TO MY OFFICE
AND TO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. AS SHE RETIRES HER
WORK WILL CERTAINLY BE MISSED
BUT I'M SURE SHE'LL APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEND MORE
TIME AROUND HER FAMILY
INCLUDING HER DAUGHTER
GABRIELLA DOMINGUEZ AND HER SON
RUBEN DOMINGUEZ- LISA ALSO
LIVES ON THE SAME STREET AS ME-
HERE IN SACRAMENTO I SHE WAKES
UP AND GOES WALKING AT THE SAME
OF SEEN OUR THAT I GET UP AND
GO JOGGING- SO SHE IS ABLE TO
BALANCE QUITE. A BIT WITH HER
JOB DUTIES AND WE'RE GOING TO
REALLY REALLY REALLY MISS LISA
AROUND HERE BUT- WE'RE EXCITED
ABOUT THE NEXT CHAPTER IN HER
LIFE SO PLEASE JOIN ME IN
CONGRATULATING ON HER WELL
DESERVED. RETIREMENT THE CITY.
OKAY MEMBERS WE ARE BACK ON THE
FILE. WE ARE AT SENATE THIRD
READING. FILE ITEMS TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE AND TWENTY SIX PASS
AND RETAIN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
TWENTY SEVEN SB THREE NINETY
ONE CORPORATION SENATE BILL
THREE NINETY ONE BY SET OF MEN
AND OTHERS AND ACCOLADES COMMON
INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS
DECLARATIVE ZERO STICK BACK
IMMEDIATELY MISS DAVIS YOU MAY
OPEN. THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT SB
THREE NINE ONE ON BEHALF OF ITS
AUTHORED MY COLLEAGUE FROM
ORANGE COUNTY SENATOR MAN. SB
THREE NINE ONE AS AN EMERGENCY
MEASURE THAT AUTHORIZES COMMON
INTEREST DEVELOPMENT BOARDS
WHICH INCLUDE H. O. A. SO SHE
SENT TO SAFELY MEET VIA
TELECONFERENCE DURING
EMERGENCIES AND DISASTERS. AND
INSURANCE SECTOR PARTICIPATION
IN THESE MEETINGS IS ACCESSIBLE
TO MEMBERS LED TO THE GOVERNOR
ISSUED EXECUTIVE ORDER ALLOWING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS STATE
AGENCIESTO MEET AND VOTE
REMOTELY DURING THE PANDEMIC.
AS IT WAS UNSAFE TO MEET IN
PERSON YET NO SIMILAR ACTION
HAS BEEN TAKEN FOR HOAS CURRENT
LAW REQUIRES HOAS PROVIDE A
PHYSICAL MEETING LOCATION FOR
ALL TELECONFERENCING MEETINGS
WHICH AS YOU CAN IMAGINE HAS
POSES SIGNIFICANT SAFETY RISKS.
IN THE MIDST OF THE ONGOING
PANDEMIC. THE AUTHOR RECENTLY
CROSSED AMENDMENTS THAT
STRENGTHEN THE THRESHOLD FOR
MEETING VIRTUALLY STATING THAT
THE NATURE OF THE EMERGENCY OR
THE DISASTER IT MUST BE SUCH
THAT IS UNSAFE TO MEET IN
PERSON DURING THE EVENT. THIS
ENSURES THAT THE BILL IS ONLY
USE DURING APPROPRIATE AND
NECESSARY TIMES THIS IS WHY SB
THREE NINETY ONE WHICH IS A
PERMISSIVE BILL THAT SUPPLIES.
SIMPLY GIVES H. AWAY OPTIONS TO
MEET SAFELY DURING TIMES OF
EMERGENCY THE SAME ABSENT
THAT'S BEEN GIVEN TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND STATE AGENCIES
IS SO URGENTLY NEEDED THANK.
YOU AND I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
DAVE NAME IS DAVIES C. NO
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION ON
THE ADAM CORPORAL. IS THAT A
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
THEM. ALL MEMBERS WILL DECIDE
TO VOTE. CLARK WELL. CLOSE A
ROLL TIDE I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
ON THE URGENCY I SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO ON THE MEASURE THAT BILL
PASSES. FILE ITEMS TWENTY EIGHT
THROUGH THIRTY PASS AND RETAIN.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
THIRTY ONE SB THREE NINETY TWO
CORPORATION SENATE BILL THREE
NINETY TWO BY SENATOR ARCHULETA
AND OTHERS IMMACULATE IN THE
COMMON INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS MR
MAYES YOU MAY OPEN I THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER MEMBERS SB THREE
NINETY TWO WILL IMPROVE
ACCESSIBILITY TO IMPORTANT
DOCUMENTS AND REDUCE DELIVERY
COSTS. ARE REQUIRING HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS TO COMMUNICATE
WITH HOMEOWNERS VIA MAIL
UNLESS A RESIDENT USES RECEIVE
COMMUNICATIONS VIA ANOTHER
METHOD SUCH AS TRADITIONAL MAIL
THIS BILL IS PIVOTAL TO
ENSURING THE DOCUMENT
DELIVERIES IN HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS ARE KEPT UP TO
DATE WITH OUR EVER CHANGING
LANDSCAPE OF INFORMATION
SHARING TECHNOLOGIES SB THREE
NINETY TWO WAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND PASS UP
THE SENATE FLOOR WITH NO NO
VOTES. THANK YOU MISTER MESS.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. CARPAL OF THE
ROLE. MEMBERS THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
OUT. WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. PASS A RETAINER
FILE ITEMS THIRTY TWO. THROUGH
THIRTY FOUR. THAT BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM THIRTY FIVE S. B. TWO
SEVENTY TWO CORKERY. SENATE
BILL TWO SEVENTY TWO BY CENTER
LAYERED AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
TO SEE GOVERNMENT CLEAR THE
YEARS EITHER UPS LIKE AFFECT ME
DEEPLY. MS BARRICADE HAND YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTY TWO BY
SENATOR WHERE'D WHICH WILL
UPDATE THE ARCHAIC LANGUAGE
CURRENTLY IN STATUTE TO ENSURE
GENDER NEUTRALITY. AMONG
VARIOUS CODE SECTIONS AND
INCREASE THE AGE LIMIT FOR
YOUNG ADULTS TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE COMMUNITY CONSERVATION
CORPS. A PRIME EXAMPLE OF THIS
ISSUE CAN BE FOUND IN THE
VEHICLE CODE WHERE PRONOUNCES
REFERENCING THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL COMMISSIONER ARE
MALE DOMINANT EVEN THOUGH
CURRENCY H. P. COMMISSIONER
AMANDA RAY NOW LEADS THE
DEPARTMENT AND USES SHE OR HER
PRONOUNS. WELL CALIFORNIA HAS
LED EFFORTS TO PROMOTE
DIVERSITY EQUALITY AND EQUITY
OUR LAWS HAVE NOT KEPT PACE
IT'S TIME THAT WE RETIRE CARE
ACT REFERENCES AND REPLACE THEM
WITH LANGUAGE THE REPRESENTS
CALIFORNIA'S BEAUTIFUL
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSIVITY.
SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTY TWO IS
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA AND IS A LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITY FOR THE LGBTQ CAUCUS.
THANK YOU IS MARKETING HERE. MR
LOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
BECAUSE I RISE IN SUPPORT AS
WELL AS THE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LGBT LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS. WORDS MATTER AND THIS
IS A REFLECTION OF OUR VALUES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU MR LOW. YOU SEEN-
DISCUSSION. OR DEBATE. ON THE
ITEM. THIS AMERICAN HENRY
CLOSER CLICK LIBERAL MEMBERS
DESERVE A ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT I. SIXTY NINE
OH ZERO ON THE URGENCY I SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO ON THE MEASURE
THAT BILL PASSES. IT'S PAST
RETAIN A PROBLEM THIRTY SIX
THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTY SEVEN.
SB FOUR FOUR TWO. OUR PRIMARY
SENATE BILL FOR FORTY TWO BY
CENTER NEWMAN AND OTHERS NOW
BILLION SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
MISTER O'DONNELL EMAIL. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT SB FOUR FOUR
TWO TO ALLOW COUNTY COMMITTEE
ON SCHOOL DISTRICT
REORGANIZATION TO CALL FOR
DISTRICT BASED ELECTIONS.
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS COUNTY
COMMITTEES THAT OVERSEE SCHOOL
DISTRICT ORGANIZATIONS TO
ESTABLISH TRUSTEE AREA
ELECTIONS HOWEVER DISTRICTS
WITH ELECTIONS GOVERNED BY THE
CHARTER OF THE CITY. OR CITY
AND COUNTY MUST GO THROUGH
EXTRA STEPS INCLUDING PUTTING A
PROPOSED ORDINANCE ON THE
BALLOT OR SEEKING A WAIVER AT
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION.
THIS BILL PROVIDES PARITY FOR
COUNTY COMMITTEE TO BE ABLE TO
CALL FOR A DISTRICT BASED
ELECTION WHETHER THE DISTRICT
IS LOCATED IN A CHARTER OR NON
CHARTER CITY. THIS BILL WILL
SAVE TIME AND MONEY AND HAS NO
NO VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
O'DONNELL. SHE NOTICED KASHER
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLERK WILL
OPEN THE- MEMBERS. DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A. CLERK WILL. CLOSER ROLE
TYLER I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. RIGHT A PASSER
RETAIN ON FILE ITEM THIRTY
EIGHT. THIS IS FILE ITEM THIRTY
NINE SB THREE SEVENTY FOUR
CORKERY SENATE BILL THREE
SEVENTY FOUR BYTES CENTER MEN
AND OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
PUT PROTECTIVE ORDERS. THIS
PETRIE-NORRIS FROM MISS IRWIN
STAFFS. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AS SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
I RISE TO PRESENT SB THREE
SEVENTY FOUR ON BEHALF OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE COUNTY
SENATOR MAN SB THREE SEVENTY
FOUR IS A FIRST IN THE NATION
BELT THAT ADDS REPRODUCTIVE
COERCION TO THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE PREVENTION ACT.
REPRODUCTIVE COERCION REFERS OF
CONTROL OVER THE REPRODUCTIVE
AUTONOMY OF ANOTHER THROUGH
THREAT OF FORCE OR INTIMIDATION
REPRODUCTIVE COERCION IS A
HORRIFIC FORM OF ABUSE AND IS
UNFORTUNATELY ALL TOO COMMON
PUTTING A NAME TO THIS
HORRENDOUS ACT IS ONE PART OF
THE SOLUTION AS IT ENABLES AND
EMPOWERS SURVIVORS TO IDENTIFY
THE ABUSE THEY HAVE
EXPERIENCED. HOWEVER THIS BILL
WILL ALSO HELP JUDGES WHO HAVE
SIGNIFICANT DISCRETION IN
ISSUING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS RECOGNIZE
THAT THIS CONDUCT IS LEGALLY
DEFINED AS ABUSE THIS CRITICAL
ADDITION TO THE TVPA WILL HELP
SURVIVORS SEEKING JUST JUSTICE
AND PROTECTION THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
ADVICE. BAKER IS PETRIE-NORRIS
MISTER LUCKY YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
YEAH JUST TO QUESTION TWO OTHER
PRISONER. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
YEAH I'M READING HERE CONCERN
THAT I WOULD LIKE SOME
CLARIFICATION TO. IT SAYS THAT-
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT THIS BILL
WHAT ON ITS FACE EMPOWER CHILD
TO OBTAIN A RESTRAINING ORDER
AGAINST A PARENT. WAS IN
REASONABLY ATTEMPTING TO
CONTROL OR LIMIT THE CHILD'S
REPRODUCTIVE ANATOMY. SUCH IS
PRESSURING THE CHILD NOT TO
ENGAGE IN SEXUAL ACTIVITY OR
NOT TO GET AN ABORTION IS THAT.
TRUE THAT IS NOT TRUE SO BY
DEFINITION REPRODUCTIVE
COERCION DEFINES A THREAT OF
VIOLENCE OR FORCE. THANK YOU IS
PETRIE-NORRIS SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION ON
THE ITEM. YOU MAY CLOSE IF YOU
WISH. AT THANK YOU I WILL JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR DR ED.
CLICK LIBERAL MEMBERS. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSE A ROLL TIDE ABOUT
ICE FIFTY FOUR NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. PASS RETAIN ON
FILE ITEM FORTY. WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE UP FILE ITEM FORTY ONE.
THIS IS SENATE BILL FOUR THIRTY
SEVEN CORPORATE. SENATE BILL
FOR THIRTY SEVEN BY CENTER BY
CAL SKI INOCULATING TO
ELECTRICITY MR HOLDEN YOU MAY
OPEN THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
ON BEHALF OF CENTER WHY CAL SKI
I RISE TO PRESENT SB FOUR
THIRTY SEVEN. WHICH WOULD
REQUIRE INTEGRATED RESOURCE
PLAN SUBMITTED BY PUBLICLY
OWNED UTILITIES TO INCLUDE
DETAILS OF AN ELECTRICITY RATE
DESIGN FOR TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION. CURRENT PLANS
ARE NOT FULLY ADDRESSING
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION
THEY ARE MOSTLY LIMITED TO
LIGHT DUTY VEHICLES AND DENIED
INCLUDE MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES EXPLICITLY PROVIDING
FOR ALL SECTORS OF
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION
INTO THESE INTEGRATED RESOURCE
PLANS INSURERS A COMPREHENSIVE
ELECTRICITY RATE DESIGN. COST
CONSIDERATIONS PRESENT
TECHNOLOGY FOR BOTH THE
VEHICLES AND THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT SUPPORTS THEM IS VITAL FOR
THE ADOPTION AND RETAIN OUR
STATE GOALS TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
AIR POLLUTION. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU MR HOLDEN.
C. NOTIFICATION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM. CARCLUB RURAL. DESIRE
TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT
A VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY SEVEN
KNOWS NINE. THAT MEASURE PASSES
PASS A RETAINER FOLLOWS FORTY
TWO THROUGH. FORTY FIVE. THIS
IS FILE ITEM FORTY SIX SB FIFTY
ONE CORPORATE. SENATE BILL
FIFTY ONE BY SENATOR ALSO AND
OTHERS IN AFRICA SURPLUS
PROPERTY IN DECLARE THE YEARS
HERE AFFECT THE COMMUNITY. THIS
CARILLO HE MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS OF THE
PROUD PRINCIPLE CO AUTHOR TO
THIS MEASURE I RISE TO PRESENT
SB FIFTY ONE ON BEHALF OF MY
SENATOR SENATOR THE DOCILE FROM
EL SERENO THIS BILL IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO MY COMMUNITY WILL
PROVIDE MEASURABLE COST SAVINGS
FOR THE STATE WHILE PRODUCING A
MODEL OF EXPANDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ENHANCING HOMEOWNERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YEARS. THE
CENTER AND I HAVE ENGAGE WITH
RESIDENTS RENTING APARTMENTS
AND HOMES FROM CALTRANS WE HAVE
URGED FAIR TREATMENT OF THESE
TENANTS ON THE EXPEDITED SALE
OF THESE PROPERTIES AT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING RATES SB
FIFTY ONE ADDRESSES AN URGENT
CRISIS IN MY COMMUNITY OF EL
SERENO THAT ALIGNS WITH THE CUT
WITH GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S
EXECUTIVE ACTIONS TO FOSTER
HOUSING INNOVATION. ON ACCESS
STATE LAND AND RAPIDLY INCREASE
HOUSING OPTIONS THIS BILL
PROVIDES A PATHWAY TO OWNERS TO
HOMEOWNERSHIP WHILE ALLOWING
FOR THE SALE OF CALTRANS
PROPERTIES TO QUALIFIED HOUSING
RELATED ENTITIES SUCH AS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND NONPROFIT
HOUSING ENTITIES AT THE
CALTRANS ORIGINAL PURCHASE
PRICE IN EXCHANGE FOR A
GUARANTEE A PROVIDING FIFTY
FIVE YEARS OF AFFORDABLE AND
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING. WITH
NEARLY ONE HUNDRED HOMES
CURRENTLY VACANT NEARLY HALF OF
THE CALTRANS HOMES IN EL SERENO
WE HAVE AN URGENT OPPORTUNITY
TO REPAIR AND IMPROVE THE
HOUSING OF THIS NEIGHBORHOOD AT
NO COST TO THE STATE AND TO
INCREASE LONG TERM AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN CALIFORNIA SB FIFTY
ONE WILL PROVIDE A LONG TERM
SOLUTION FOR HEALING AND
BUILDING WEALTH INEQUITY IN THE
COMMUNITY THROUGH HOMEOWNERSHIP
FOCUS ON THE PRIMARY GOAL OF
EXPANDING. AND PRESERVING
AFFORDABILITY OF ALL THESE
PROPERTIES WHILE PROTECTING THE
RIGHTS OF THE TENANTS AND. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
PERU. C. NOTIFICATION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. A COUPLE OF NARAL
MEMBERS. WE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRABLE. WELL.
CLOSE A ROLL TIDE I SIXTY KNOWS
TEN ON THE URGENCY I SIXTY
KNOWS TEN ON THE MEASURE. THAT
BILL PASSES WE ARE AT FILE ITEM
FORTY SEVEN SB FOUR SIXTY ONE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATOR FOR
SIXTY ONE MY CYNICAL TEASING
ACCOLADE OF BUSINESS MISTER
KALRA YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS SENATE
BILL FOR SIXTY ONE BY SENATOR
CORTESE BRINGS PARITY FOR
COUNTY COUNCILS OF LARGE
POPULATIONS TO BRING ACTION
UNDER CALIFORNIA'S UNFAIR
COMPETITION LAW. CITY ATTORNEYS
ALREADY HAVE THIS AUTHORITY AS
WELL AS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND DISTRICT ATTORNEYS.
CURRENTLY AS BEFORE SIXTY ONE A
GRANT THIS ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY TO THE STATE'S THREE
LARGEST COUNTY COUNCIL OFFICES
LOS ANGELES. ALLIES OF OTHER
IMPORTANT CONSUMER PROTECTION
STATUTES IN CALIFORNIA SUCH AS
THE FALSE ADVERTISING LAW WHICH
BROADLY AUTHORIZES COUNTY
COUNCILS TO COMBAT DECEPTIVE
BUSINESS PRACTICES. BY CLOSING
THIS ENFORCEMENT GAPS IN THE
UNFAIR COMPETITION LAW ALLOW
OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
BETTER PROTECT CONSUMERS AND
PROMOTE FAIR COMPETITION WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
KALRA. SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. CARCLUB THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS WILL THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRABLE. CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AS FIFTY
ONE KNOWS TWENTY THAT MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEMS FORTY EIGHT
THROUGH FIFTY FIVE PASS. AND
RETAIN. WE ARE A CONSENT
CALENDAR MEMBERS. DOES ANY
MEMBER WHICH REMOVE AN ITEM
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATE HEARING ON. THE
CORPORATE REED IN THE SECOND
DAY CONSENT CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION THIRTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN RELATIVE TO WILDLIFE
MITIGATION. CLERK WILL CALL THE
ROLL. ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. THIS IS THE
KANSEN CALENDAR. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TELL A. RIVER I
SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
CLERK WILL READ THE REMAINING
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION THREE I
SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO. IN THE
ABSENCE OF OBJECTION WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS. OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS WE ARE ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
ORTEGA CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR AT THIS TIME.
MEMBERS WE'RE TO GERMAN TO
MEMORY. PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFFER THE GREEN
CARPET MEMBERS. SO WE MAY
PROCEED. THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS
REGRETTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON AND ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. MR COOLEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK.MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I'M VERY
HONORED TODAY TO A RISE. IN
HONOR OF. MANUAL MANY VAL. MR
VAL WAS A US ARMY AIR CORPS
VETERAN AS WAS MY FATHER. AND
IN THIS STATE HE SERVED AS A
FORMER DIRECTOR OF VETERANS
AFFAIRS WHICH I'LL GET TO IN A
MOMENT. BUT FROM HIS AS A YOUNG
MAN HE JOINED THE ARMY AIR
CORPS HE WAS THE ONE I ALLUDED
TO WHO WAS INJURED IN AUGUST OF
NINETEEN FORTY FOUR- AND- THE
NATURE OF HIS INJURY ACTUALLY
YOU SORT OF REALIZE HOW. ALL IN
HE WAS. A MANY VAL WAS LEFT
HANDED. AND HE LOST THE USE OF
HIS LEFT ARM FOR THE REST OF
HIS LIFE. AND SO HE WAS ALL IN
ON SERVING HIS NATION. AND HIS
FELLOW. SOLDIERS L. TERRY
COLLEAGUES HIS WHOLE LIFE. AND
WAS ALWAYS ACTUALLY AND PLACES
OF RISK WHEN YOU KIND OF THINK
ABOUT THE NATURE OF HIS CAREER
WHEN MANY VAL DI HE WAS NINETY
SEVEN. IT JUST BOGGLES MY MIND
TO THINK OF A LIFETIME OF
SERVICE TO DIE NINETY SEVEN THE
PATRIARCH OF HIS FAMILY. LIVING
HERE IN CARMICHAEL CALIFORNIA.
HE WAS BORN ON CHRISTMAS DAY
NINETEEN TWENTY THREE. ELDEST
OF NINE CHILDREN BORN TO ONE
DELIVER SINCE YOU'LL AND
WALKING ASSOCIATED ON THAT DAY.
HE JOINED THE U. S. ARMY AIR
CORPS AT NINETEEN TO BECOME
THAT RADIO OPERATOR ON A B.
SEVENTEEN IN THE EUROPEAN
THEATER. TO BE INJURED AT THE
TIME OF THE VARIOUS NORMANDY
AND FRENCH LANDINGS- IN THE
SECOND WORLD WAR. HE WAS
EMPLOYED FIRST AS HE CAME OUT
HE RETURNED TO. CALIFORNIA MET
HIS WIFE AND WAS EMPLOYED WITH
THE. DISABLED AMERICAN VETERANS
WHERE HE VISION BECAME THE
DIRECTOR OF THEIR PROGRAM HERE
IN THE STATE. IN NINETEEN SIXTY
HE JOINED THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS. AFFAIRS
AND HE EVENTUALLY UNDER JERRY
BROWN IN THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES
WAS APPOINTED DIRECTOR OF THAT
AGENCY HERE IN CALIFORNIA. BUT
HE HAD OTHER THINGS GOING ON
THIS THIS HONORED AIR FORCE
VETERAN LOST THE USE OF HIS
ARM. IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES
PRESIDENT KENNEDY WAS VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT OUR
RELATIONSHIPS THROUGHOUT OUR
WESTERN HEMISPHERE. AND-
KENNEDY FOUNDED SOMETHING KNOWN
AS THE ALLIANCE FOR PROGRESS
WHICH WAS AN EFFORT BY THE
UNITED STATES TO REACH OUT TO
OTHER NATIONS IN OUR HEMISPHERE
AND BECOME INVOLVED WITH THE
PEOPLE OF NATIONS FOR THE
PROSPERITY OF ALL. ONE OF THE
CHALLENGING NATIONS. ARE WAS
CHILE. AND MANY VAL WAS
ACTUALLY SELECTED BY PRESIDENT
KENNEDY TO LEAD THE ALLIANCE
FOR PROGRESS IN CHILE WHICH
AGAIN JUST SAYS THREE THIS CAN
I BE IN A RADIO OPERATOR ON A
B. SEVENTEEN GOING INTO A PLACE
OF GREAT CHALLENGE. FOR THE
STATE FOR SENIORS HIGH BY OUR
NATION. AND UNDERTAKING PUBLIC
SERVICE. HE EVENTUALLY WENT ON
HE WAS APPOINTED IN VARIOUS
WAYS FIRST BY JESS UNRUH TO A
SPECIAL ROLE AS THE FIRST
EXECUTIVE SECRETARY OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEBT LIMIT
ALLOCATION COMMITTEE THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN AND- FRAZIER UNRESTS
ERA. ALSO WAS A MEMBER OF THE
BOARD OF VOCATIONAL NURSES
SECTOR FOR TEXAS EXAMINERS THAT
WAS A GEORGE DEUKMEJIAN
APPOINTMENT. SO REPRESENT
PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE. AND FOR THOSE WHO KNEW
MANY HE WAS TIRESOME DEVOTED TO
GIVING BACK IN EVERY ASPECT OF
HIS LIFE BUT I THINK YOU SEE
THAT. IN WARTIME IN THE SERVICE
OF OTHERS WHO WERE INJURED. IN
THE SERVICE OF VETERANS
GENERALLY IN A SERVICE SERVICE
HEMISPHERE AND IN THE SERVICE
OF THE STATE AND VARIOUS
GOVERNOR'S. HE IS SURVIVED BY
HIS OF. SIBLINGS CILIA JOHN
LYDIA GILBERT SONS CHARLES VAL
AND STEVENS VAL AND
GRANDCHILDREN AND GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN SISTERS IN LAWS
NIECES NEPHEWS EXTENDED FAMILY
AND FRIENDS I DO WANT TO NOTE
THAT I KNOW HE WAS PROVIDE
EXTENDED CARE. OF BY CARE GIVER
LUBA TERROR SILVA SO ONE OF
DOLLARS LUBIN WHAT SHE GAVE
THIS CALIFORNIAN LONG DEVOTED
CALIFORNIA IN HIS LIFE. AND
IT'S AN HONOR THAT WE ADJOURN
IN MEMORY TODAY OF MANUAL MANNY
VAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU MUCH COOLEY. AND MR MEDINA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
GERMAN MEMORY THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. AND HE
SAID THOUGH CHAU WAS BORN ONE
OF TWELVE CHILDREN. ON AUGUST.
TWENTY FIVE NINETEEN FORTY FIVE
AND LOCAL HOMEOWNERS LEVEL THEY
OWN MAY HE GO. HE WAS COMMONLY
KNOWN AND KNOWN THROUGHOUT
RIVERSIDE AS CHATTEL. AS HIS
PARENTS AND SIBLINGS CALLED HIM.
HE WAS VERY PROUD TO BE NAMED
AFTER HIS FATHER. IN HIS
PRETEEN YEARS IN MEXICO HE
ENJOYED BEING AN ENTERTAINER
PARTICIPATING AND STREET CORNER
PERFORMANCES SCHOOL COMEDIES
AND PLAYS. AT THE AGE OF TWELVE
HE HAD TO LEAVE THOSE DREAMS
BEHIND AS HIS FAMILY MOVED TO
SOUTH TEXAS IN PURSUIT OF THE
AMERICAN DREAM. HIS FAMILY
FOLLOWED THE SEASONAL HARVEST
FROM STATE TO STATE. WORKING
VERY HARD TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE
FAMILY BILLS AT SUCH AN EARLY
AGE. CHECK THOSE TEENAGE AND
EARLY ADULT LIFE. WAS SPENT IN
SANTA SENT TO CALIFORNIA. WHERE
HE MET HIS WIFE CONNIE. IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO HE TOOK A
LONG FORCING POSITION IN MEXICO.
COUNTY BECAME HOMESICK THEY
BOTH RETURNED BACK TO SENTENCE
INTO. NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT HE
TOOK A POSITION WITH THE
RIVERSIDE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT HE SERVED THIRTY ONE
YEARS RETIRING AS A PLANT
SUPERVISOR IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT. DURING THOSE THIRTY ONE
YEARS HE ONLY MISSED THREE DAYS
OF WORK. TO ATTEND THE FUNERAL
OF HIS PARENTS AND BROTHER. HIS
ON HIS WORK ETHIC. WAS
UNTOUCHABLE. I FIRST MET CHAT
THOUGH WHEN I WAS A BRAND NEW
TEACHER AT POLY HIGH SCHOOL.
THERE WAS NO ONE AT POLY HIGH
SCHOOL THAT GAVE ME BETTER
ADVICE THAN CHAPTER. HE TAUGHT
ME THE INS AND OUTS. TELL ME
WHERE WHAT I NEEDED TO LOOK OUT
FOR AND HELPME TO BE A
SUCCESSFUL TEACHER. CHETO
PASSED AWAY ON JUNE TWENTY
NINTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE. HE'S
LEFT HE LEAVES BEHIND FOUR SONS
NINE GRANDCHILDREN AND FOUR
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN. I ASK THAT
WE ADJOURN IN MY GOOD FOR IN
MEMORY OF MY GOOD FRIEND JET
THOUGH A CHILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MUCH MEDINA. AND MR
BELOW ME ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
GERMAN IN MEMORY THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF RHONDA MEISTER A CONSTITUENT
AND COLLEAGUES WHO IS BEST
KNOWN AS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE ST JOSEPH CENTER A
HIGHLY REGARDED HOMELESS
SERVICE AGENCY ON THE WEST SIDE
OF LOS ANGELES. RHONDA WAS BORN
IN NINETEEN FORTY NINE AND UPON
GRADUATING FROM HIGH SCHOOL
ENTERED THE SISTERS OF
PROVIDENCE LATER RECEIVING HER
BA FROM NUTAN COLLEGE OF THE
SACRED HEART. AS A SISTER SHE
SERVED AS A HOSPITAL CASE
MANAGER AND LATER ON STAFF AT
CATHOLIC CHARITIES IN BOSTON
BEFORE LEAVING THE COMMUNITY IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO. AND AFTER
COMPLETING HER MASTER'S OF
DIVINITY. RHONDA MOVED WEST IN
LOS ANGELES SHE FIRST WORKED AT
THE HOUSE OF RUTH BEFORE
JOINING THE STAFF AT SAINT
JOSEPH CENTER IN VENICE. AS A
CASE MANAGER AND THEN IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX. SHE WAS
NAMED ITS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
FOR THE NEXT TWENTY TWO YEARS
RHONDA LED THE CENTER WITH
COMMITMENT ENTHUSIASM AND
INSPIRATION. UNDER HER
LEADERSHIP THE AGENCY GREW FROM
A GRASSROOTS EFFORT OF TWELVE
STAFF MEMBERS IN A ROSE AVENUE
STOREFRONT. TO AN AGENCY
EMPLOYING MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED
STAFF PROVIDING EDUCATIONAL
SOCIAL VOCATIONAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FROM EIGHT
LOCATIONS ON THE WEST SIDE.
ADDITIONALLY RHONDA SERVED ON
THE BOARD AS CHAIR OF THE WEST
SIDE COALITION ON HUNGER AND
HOMELESSNESS. AND THE ADVISORY
BOARD OF THE LOS ANGELES
HOMELESS SERVICES AUTHORITY
LHASA AMONG OTHER WORTHY CAUSES.
AMONG HER LEGACIES WAS THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF BREAD AND
ROSES CAFE A FULL SERVICE
RESTAURANT SERVING ADULTS AND
FAMILIES WITHOUT HOMES AND
ADDITIONALLY PROVIDING TRAINING
IN CULINARY ARTS TO LOW INCOME
WORKERS. IN CONJUNCTION WITH
HER LEADERSHIP AT SAINTJOSEPH
CENTER RHONDA WAS ALSO A
RESPECTED ADVOCATE WHO WORKED
TO ESTABLISH EFFECTIVE PUBLIC
POLICY AND RAISE PUBLIC
AWARENESS OF THE NEEDS OF OUR
LOW INCOME DISABLED AND ON
HOUSE NEIGHBORS. I WAS
FORTUNATE TO HAVE THE PLEASURE
OF WORKING CLOSELY WITH RHONDA
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS WELL I
SERVED ON THE SANTA MONICA CITY
COUNCIL. AS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF SAINT JOSEPH
CENTER. RHONDA WAS INSTRUMENTAL
IN DEVELOPING INNOVATIVE
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
POLICIES. THAT HELPED SHAPE
SANTA MONICA POLICY AND IN
SURROUNDING AREAS. RHONDA
PASSED AWAY ON JUNE FIFTEENTH
AFTER A LONG BATTLE WITH
CANCER. WHILE HER HUSBAND
PRECEDED HER IN DEATH SHE IS
SURVIVED BY HER DAUGHTER
MULHOLLAND HER BROTHER AND
SISTERS AND THEIR EXTENDED
FAMILIES AN ASSET WE ADJOURN
THE MEMORY OF RHONDA MEISTER.
THANK YOU AS WELL. THANK YOU
MEMBERS MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS
MEMBERS THE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE WILL BE
MEETING IN THIS CHAMBER. THIRTY
MINUTES UPON ADJOURNMENT.%
THAT'S GEO COMMITTEE IN THIS
CHAMBER THIRTY MINUTES UPON
ADJOURNMENT THIRTY MINUTES
AFTER A GERMAN I SHOULD SAY.
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY JULY THIRTEENTH CHECK
IN SESSION WEDNESDAY JULY
FOURTEENTH CHECKING SESSION
THURSDAY JULY FIFTEENTH BEFORE
SESSION IS AT NINE AM ALL OTHER
ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE PASSED
TO RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED. SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY
TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN. MISTER GIBSON MOVES
AND MR VOEPEL SECONDS. THAT
THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY JULY FIFTEENTH
AT NINE AM IN THE QUORUM CALL
IS LIFTED.
WELL OKAY VOTE
CHANGE COOPER FILE ITEM. TWELVE
EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY EIGHT FROM
I TO NOT VOTING. NO CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE SEVENTY EIGHT- TO NOT
VOTING.